MARK MIRCHANDANI:
On this episode,
we talked to doc.ai
about how they
use Federated Learning to
preserve privacy while training
machine learning models.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So going back to
your application,
you kind of mentioned that AI
was used for the patients that
are using it.
Tell us a little bit more
about the actual app.
AKSHAY SHARMA: Yeah, so we have
the medical research companion
app.
And what it allows you
to do is basically be
able to collect some
important omics information.
And we have reduced the friction
to be able to collect that.
Like I mentioned earlier, you
can take a medical selfie which
is just a selfie, but it
extracts medical information
out of that.
We can extract mood
and behavioral data out
of that selfie.
But we can also take
pictures of your pill bottles
and understand what medication
and dosage and instructions
that exist on those.
We can do that
pretty much for lab
results and medical
records very soon.
We can also collect your
genetic information.
So we don't do wet
sequencing, meaning,
that we don't get you sequenced.
But we can collect
any of the raw data
that you have sequenced
yourself, for example,
from 23andMe or Ancestry, and be
able to bring that into the app
and keep it in the app and then
understand what's in the data.
So one is it's all about
polyomics data collection
that the app allows you to do.
But on the other
side, we basically
run what we call as
data trials, which
is the new version of what
medical research looks
like where we can actually
take users vertically,
based on their
disease or conditions,
and use the data that they've
collected so far to lead them
towards this research
with the right consent
and the right options so that
they can participate and get
some rewards.
The rewards could be
financial, but it will also
be more than that, like
insights and other predictions
that we can give on top of that.
So largely, the
medical companion app
is a medical research app that
allows patients to understand
and see what are the newer ways
that they can find solutions
for their diseases today.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
How does the cloud
enable that collection and
then actual using of that data?
AKSHAY SHARMA: Right, so
we see that in many ways.
So first of all,
for some something
like medical selfie, which
is basically a deep learning
model that we have
built, we have built it
on the cloud across
a lot of data
that we were able to
collect painstakingly
through different techniques.
So the medical selfie
is a deep learning model
that can take an image
or a selfie of your face
and be able to predict
your sex, height, weight,
and age as parameters
out of that,
but then also creates further
predictions out of that.
So now that's a model that
we built on the cloud--
on Google Cloud-- using a lot
of computational resources.
Then we were able to
convert that model
to run on a mobile device.
So we were able to take that
and made it do edge inferences.
So we can run it on a
phone, and it can actually
predict those variables
just sitting on the phone
without really revealing
or taking any of the images
that the patient or the member
is taking back to the server.
So one thing that I see
there is that cloud enables
us to build models
like this that today
is much harder to build
just on the phone.
But with newer approaches
like Federated Learning,
we can actually also train
and build models on the phone
across many, many, many users,
like hundreds of thousands
of users.
So we may not need cloud
to even centralize the data
at some point in the future.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what
exactly does Federated Learning
enable for the users who
are using the application?
AKSHAY SHARMA: That's
a great question.
So I think health
care data in general
is a very valuable asset.
And I think it's highly
secure and private data
that every user
and every patient
should actually care for.
So we think the future of where
all of the health information
will exist is only on
the edge, specifically
on the mobile phones
for the users.
And I think it's easy for
them to lose that information
and send it to a cloud if
they're not aware of how
that data is being used.
So what we can do with
Federated Learning now
is provide guarantees for users
that it can stay on the device.
But then we don't lose the
aspect of learning something
from the data, wherein
we can now build models
that can train on the device.
And we can build a better
model on the server
by just sort of sharing the
device-trained information,
which is usually like bits
of information, like numbers,
but not the real data itself.
And imagine now
if we can do that
across a population of users
like hundreds of thousands
of users, then what we
get behind the scenes
is a much more robust model
that's much more diverse.
And hopefully, it's much
more generalized than as
if it was trained
on a single user.
So that's what Federated
Learning can do.
And then we can add layers
of security and tools
like differential privacy
where we don't even
learn anything about the
person that we are training on.
So in combination with
differential privacy
and Federated
Learning, I think we
have a very important
solution where
we can keep the data
on the edge and still
be able to learn
something from the data
without knowing who the user
is or what's in the data.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Stay tuned for
more conversations with doc.ai.
If you enjoyed this episode,
check out the Stack Chat
playlist for more great videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]